hey what's up guys my name is Jonah
welcome back to my game engine series so
last time we took a look at U of W and
sending events from GL of W into our
event system definitely check out that
video if you haven't already and today
we're gonna be taking a look at
something called a layer stack and
essentially layers and what they are in
in a game engine in our game engine and
how we're gonna use them and we're gonna
take a more practical approach to this
I'm just going to show you guys a bunch
of code that I've already written that
makes all that stuff kind of happen and
we might have a theory video in there
sometime in the future I don't think
it's that necessary right now at least
because it's quite a simple concept I
think you guys will get it once you see
some code and that might be a better way
of explaining what it actually does
first of all I want to give you a huge
thank you to all the patrons that make
this series possible if you guys aren't
supporting series you can do so by going
by going over to patreon icon for
session the channel you'll get the code
to a much more advanced version of hazel
already available to all of you guys
which has all this stuff like way
implemented as well as all of these
videos will kind of come out one week
earlier for you guys well it's just a
really good way to help support this
because I do have two I do have a
full-time job outside of this and it's
kind of hard for me to allocate time for
this but because of the support from the
community I'm able to actually spend a
lot more time on this and I would have
otherwise so huge thank you to all those
people for making this possible
okay so layers what are layers whenever
I whenever I talk about layers to people
I usually end up comparing them to
something like Photoshop which isn't
like a great comparison I think because
obviously that's not as interactive as
something like a game engine but you can
think of it as a layer in Photoshop
where you basically have an ordered list
kind of of lettuce or layer stack as
it's kind of cold usually and whenever
you kind of want to draw something on
the screen layers determine what order
things are drawn in both thing is they
don't just determine what order things
are drawn in and also layers aren't just
applicable to graphics layers in a game
engine also is they're also primarily
applicable to events and also things
like update logic right so we know that
at the moment our game in the
application
has a run function which basically has a
while loop that keeps kind of iterating
over and over and over again until I
game actually stops us call that game
loop right so what actually will happen
here is every layer that is inside that
layer stack which is currently kind of
visible a currently enabled right same
way that you can kind of turn layers on
and off in Photoshop and just hide them
essentially or disable them you can do
the same thing here as well whenever a
layer kind of is enabled then as we go
through that game loop each layer will
be updated in the order that it actually
appears in that layer stack as well
right through that kind of update loop
you can do rendering on that layer and
obviously since the layer stack is
ordered that's very important because it
means that you can put layers on top of
other layers which will kind of
determine draw order and it's also very
useful for things like overlays in fact
it's even very useful for overlays to
the point where I've actually built in
like an overlay system into the layer
stack which enables you to kind of push
I guess layers to the second half of the
layer stack so basically we have like we
have one one contiguous list of layers
but kind of overlays are always at the
end of that list so they get rendered
last which is very important because if
we decide that we want to I don't know
render a gizmo or render some kind of
debug graphics which we want to have
always on top of anything that we render
then we we need to render it last
there's no real way about it we need to
basically disable death testing and then
render that thing last and that's how
yes I need to be on top of everything so
layers laser can leave one for that but
the other big thing with layers is
events now this is where it works the
other way around
whereas we kind of have a list of layers
and we go through them kind of in order
from 0 to you know size minus 1
essentially we go through them in order
with events we kind of go the other way
right because if you think about it if I
go and click my mouse on something then
the first layer that should receive that
event is actually the last rented layer
because if we draw a button that is
rendered on top of everything else since
rendered last that should be the first
thing that receives the event and then
if that decides to handle the event
and in marketers handled then it does
not need to get propagated further down
the layer stack into the other layers
such as our 3d game world because
obviously if we have a big button on the
screen and we click it we don't want our
character to shoot his gun as well for
example it is like a first-person
shooter again because that has been
handled by the thing that's on top right
so we kind of have this kind of um you
know going kind of forwards through the
list and going back through the list for
through the list to render it and update
it and do all that all that kind stuff
and then we go backwards in order to
kind of handle events or buy back what I
just mean we kind of started them at the
topmost layer and we we work our way
down what's instead of going from the
bottom up like we would with render and
that's pretty much it so to sum up what
a layer is a layer is quite an abstract
concept it's just what it is it's kind
of like it's kind of like a section of
your game that is kind of a section of
your application that renders certain
kind of things and also receives events
right that sounds very vague and when we
get into it
we'll definitely it'll probably
definitely make more sense but if you
think of it it kind of practically it
might make more sense if you have like a
3d game world let's say we're making
like a 3d game or whatever we have our
pretty game while that's it's on one
layer all the three all of the 3d
rendering gets done on that layer that's
kind of like our game layer any events
that happen as well get kind of sent
into that layer and that is kind of
almost that layer is like the root to
the rest of the game it holds our scene
right that's what it is everything kind
of stems from that game layer then we
might have like a debug layer or
something on top of that as like a game
world debug layer this is basically
something that might only get pushed
onto the layer stack in debug builds and
this will have maybe something like I
don't know just some kind of debug
graphic some kind of you know hitbox
regions or like things that like cubes
that get drawn or read like you know
cubes to get drawn on like certain
characters because like when they get
hit with a bullet or like any kind of
debug graphics that exist in a 3d world
might be on that layer and then we might
have like a UI layer in our game which
is a 2d kind of orthographical
projection that's another way that layer
is kind of tie and usually you would
have one
projection for that layer obviously you
can always switch projection and start
rendering something else in a layer
that's also perfectly valid but another
good way to maybe imagine that division
is if you just had like a UI layer which
you know has an orthographic projection
holds all of the UI do game that could
be on a separate layer and then in fact
that would probably need to be on a
separate layer because when you click on
a button you would want it not to
propagate down to the game layer because
that click event might do something else
and you want to essentially block that
and then on top of that you might have
like another debug graphics layer that's
kind of for 2d graphics there might be
just like I am gooey or something like
that or some kind of you know menu items
or buttons that you can click to trigger
certain events that shouldn't be there
and like debug builds or anything like
that sorry
interlaced build or distribution builds
but might you might want to have it in
like debug builds or you know release
builds kind of in-house release builds
so that you can kind of trigger certain
events or really you know load certain
levels just extra functionality
essentially so that that could be a
practical way of kind of looking at
layers all they are I just kind of
against groups of your your application
that receive events and usually render
some kind of graphics ok anyway let's
jump in and start implementing this I
don't think there's this not that much
code so I'll kind of walk you guys
through it and hopefully that in itself
will kind of be enough and we'll also
create an example layer just to see how
to use the API
ok so what I've done here is I've got
git diff tool up with beyond compare
again just to show you guys everything
that I've done but the first thing I'll
do is I'll actually show you guys the
new classes so there's four new files
layer stack dot Agency VP and layer
agency VP will sell it layer this is
again really simple I don't want you to
kind of picture this as like some
complex thing it can be used very
powerful and we'll probably add stuff to
it in the future but for now it's really
quite a simple implementation basically
what we have right now is a layer which
optionally takes in a name if you don't
provide a name it just calls itself
layer this is more or less a debug named
layers shouldn't really have names in
distribution builds because you
shouldn't be addressing layers by names
anyway
so this is kind of all for debug
purposes um you know I mean not saying
that like it would be that you know bad
for performance if you did have a name
being stored per layer but it's just
like again you can see I haven't put map
cursor around this to disable it in
distribution builds I'm just kind of
making it clear that it's a debug name
so that you don't start using this stuff
when trying to find layers or whatever
because you really shouldn't be doing
that we have on attach on detach on
update and on event
so whenever layer is attached basically
when a layer is pushed on to the layer
stack and part of our application we
attach it we can detach it as well when
it gets removed there that's basically I
can on an it a non shutdown type of
thing we have on update which gets
called by the application when the layer
is updated which should happen every
frame and then we have an event which is
whenever an event gets sent to the
layout we receive it here it's all
virtual so you can all kind of override
this when you make your own layer so the
way this is intended to be used is you
basically basically subclass this class
and then you implement anything you want
and that's your layer and then that when
you do create a class that's like your
game layer or something and you do have
all of this in it you push it into the
application as you'll see in a minute
and it kind of gets gets put into that
layer stack and thus gets updated and
receives events and all that kind of
stuff happens um one thing I haven't put
in here yet deliberately is the kind of
enabling disabling of layers will do
that a little bit further down the road
because I don't wanna complicate things
too much but basically you would usually
have either in the layer class itself or
boolean which says whether or not it's
enabled and it allows you to disable the
layer which means that it will not be
updated thus it will not render um and
also one receive events so basically
just kind of hides it from the from the
look from the layer stack um or you
could actually have that that bullying
um being stored in the layer stack as
well if you wanted to okay the secret
base side of this is really simple we
have an empty destructor obviously we
need a virtual destructor because this
is going to be subclassed and then we
just basically just saw the name and
that's it so dead simple now the layer
stack is a little bit more complicated
than that because what the layer stack
is is essentially
wrapper over this vector of layers now
we're using a vector because every frame
this will be iterated over there will
need to be a reverse iterator as well
because we need to propagate events in a
reverse fashion but for things like
updates we always need iterate through
it so there's no like real reason this
should be like oh and also the reason
it's not an actual stat is because it's
because we actually ended up pushing
things into the middle of it as you'll
see with overlays but anyway the idea is
that we want some kind of contiguous
data storage I'm also just storing raw
pointers here no reason to really wrap
this up in shed pointers or unique
pointers or anything like that it's
really a dead simple kind of system here
the that is easier to handle and in
terms of ownership and all that layers
are owned by the layer stack as soon as
you give it to the layer stack so when
you push that pointer into the layer
stack you can see here it pushes it into
the right place and then obviously when
the layers that gets destroyed it gets
deleted now the other thing is when you
pop layers I should say the ownership
here is a little bit interesting because
when we pop layers we don't lose them
it's only when the layers that gets
destroyed now here's the thing the layer
stack is owned by the application which
means that basically the way this works
is you can allocate your layer and as
long as you give it to the layer stack
and don't take it out you will be
de-allocated when the application shuts
down
okay so layers are kind of intended to
live throughout the lifetime of your
application at this given point in time
in the future of course if you change
levels or you do something like that it
would it might be worth recreating the
entire layer stack but again in that
sense you would in fact to recreate the
entire layer stack which means all the
layers get deleted by this destructor
okay so the ownership kind of typed like
during your during the duration of the
layer stack everything is tied to the
layer stack however if you pop a layer
temporarily you can push it back in and
you won't like it double layer will not
be deleted
it'll just be removed from the it'll be
just removed from this actual vector but
it's not going to get to it so there's
the ownership semantics if you really
care about like my stuff anyway
pushing layers and all that stuff is
really really simple layers get pushed
into the first half of the list as I
said and then overlays get pushed into
the second half of the list is basically
how it works and there's some code
around here to make that happen
the reason it's done that way is because
overlay is we always want to render last
if we push an overlay just at any point
we always want to ensure that it
suddenly gets put into the very very
very end right whereas if we push a
layer it gets pushed before the overlays
so it'll get pushed as the last layer
but not kind of in it will never be in
front of overlays overlays will always
be after layers that's kind of why
there's some code here to make sure that
it gets pushed into certain places for
example overlays you can see get pushed
into the very back of the list whereas
layers get pushed into this kind of
layer insert area which also changes
every time we you know remove or add a
layer right so that kind of makes sure
all the layers get pushed into the first
half of the list okay so that is
basically it and then we have this
implementation of begin and end so that
we can use this in a range based for
loop as we'll do in the application
class so that's pretty much all there is
to it again what this layer stack is is
really just a wrapper around this kind
of layers thing I could probably type
def this actual collection or I mean
they're using it just so that we
wouldn't have to write it all the time
here but especially for the iterator I
guess but I've made it a little bit more
clear in this video at least maybe in
the future something that we can change
okay cool that's it that those are the
new files now let's take a look at the
changes that have happened so in
application @h apart from sorting out
these kind of includes i've added two
new functions push layer and push
overlay which just take in that layer as
you can see there's no way to kind of
pop them yet which is fine as well this
is supposed to be a simple a simple kind
of first step implementation and then we
also have a layer stack which you can
see is just credit on the stack here and
that's kind of inherit the lifetime of
this application class okay that's
pretty simple now this is where it gets
a little bit more exciting so obviously
this is very
simple we just push and we just this is
just a wrapper essentially we just push
it to the light stack as a layer or an
overlay but then we have own event and
and the run thing run thing really
simple as you can see we just kind of
fuse we just iterate over all the layers
and layer stuff we can use that range
based for loop here because we
implemented begin and end and it just
called an update really simple kind of
goes from the beginning at the end
includes overlays obviously and that's
just what it does and then here we kind
of have to go backwards right so we go
backwards through the layer stack and we
call on event whenever an event is
received if the event is marked as
handled we break which means we do not
continue this also means that if an
overlay handles an event that's it right
layers will not get it which is the
intended behavior okay that is it
okay so in Hazleton h which is that kind
of public client-facing header file just
add a layer on H here layer of course is
included by application so I didn't
really need to do that because latex
included and all that but I did that
anyway just to kind of be both clear
because layer is definitely something
that should be accessible by the client
now in the pre make file what I actually
had to do was this kind of a bug that we
had before I basically set the build
options to include the multi-threaded
debug DLL and the multi-threaded DLL
right because what we had before and
this is for the release for the runtime
library for the safest loss runtime
library we were linking statically
against this which is an issue because
since this actually this hazel thing
builds the DLL we ended up with kind of
different heaps essentially for both the
sandbox and the hazel
and the hazel project because they were
both getting statically linked into
those respective projects we can't have
that because in a way that I kind of
found out about this was I think SPG log
and that ended up trying to free some
memory that was allocated by different
heap and that crashed ok so you need to
make sure that if you are building a DLL
that you link against the actual DLL
version at the wrong time I'll show you
guys in Visual Studio it's just under C
C++ code generation and then the runtime
library okay so it's or it I think by
default
set a multi-threaded multi-threaded
debug like it is here it should be
multi-threaded debug DLL okay so we need
to link against the DLL version and in
pre make if we do MDD like that which i
think is a switch i mean if you look
over here empty yeah that's kind of the
switch okay so you can see that over
here I've kind of done MDD which enables
that swish now yes it is controversial
that it kind of shows up is
multi-threaded debug here but I think I
don't know if there's an actual way to
set it in pretty make to not be that
okay so we kind of just include that and
then I'm not sure if as visual studios a
fault that is not propagated here but
anyway I'm not sure about that actually
that might be if you guys know about
this because obviously it's kind of
annoying that it shows up wrong here and
then gets overwritten by the additional
command line here um maybe I've done
something wrong but it seemed it
definitely seems to be linking the
correct version of the library now so we
just did that to both sandbox and and to
the hazel project to make sure that
we're linking the right runtime version
of the right runtime library version
because again we want the DLL we don't
want the static library okay sandbox app
is where I did my example layout which
I'll show you guys in a minute and then
I think that's it okay so not too many
changes at all so if we go to our
applique tower sandbox app this is my
example layout so this is how you make a
layup oh yeah and this is in the client
of course so all you have to do is
basically subclass this layout right
into your own layout you can give it a
name if you want and then I've just
implemented on update and on event okay
two little functions here in here I'm
just logging update right because this
should get updated every frame and then
of course on event I'm just logging the
event because we're not really doing
anything with it yet and then inside my
hazel application which is sandbox all I
have to do is push that later okay so
I'll just push that new example layout
into that layer stack and that's it I
could push it as an overlay that would
be totally fine as well but I just
pushed it SOA oh and so if we were on
this little program of ours one thing I
want to point out quickly that I noticed
in the output here I'm just docked this
over here so to build was that you can
see that it's actually overriding that
multi-threaded debug with with
this MVD option which is the
multi-threaded debug DLL okay
so it is in fact obviously linking the
right version but not great that it's
having to override it because it would
be nice if it was said I'm not sure I
own premake if you can do that directly
anyway so here we have this I'll kind of
leave this here I guess so you can see
the the layer is being updated all the
time and if I move my mouse or types and
keys or whatever it's receiving all
those events and if I kind of just pause
this you can see Hazel's getting the
event the event first and then our app
is actually getting the event so this
this log is coming from our example
layer this log is coming from call
because if you look at the application
thing we actually have this edge set
Court race which I can get rid of now
which traces kind of all the events that
are actually received okay cool so that
is that we are going to very soon have a
way more practical example of this
because our next step is actually going
to be the ad I am gooey to Hazel so that
we can get some basic UI going and you
know we can start displaying stuff on
the actual screen instead of in logs so
that's going to kind of be our next step
and of course for that what we will do
is create an IM GUI layer which will
hand all of the events that we need to
propagate to i'm GUI as well as also
handle all of the rendering so that's
kind of the future if you want to see
where this is headed and then obviously
from there once we start working on like
the 3d render or the 2d renderer we'll
have a layer as well for kind of our 3d
world or for our 2d world or whatever so
that is kind of where this is heading
anyway I hope you guys enjoy this video
EP dizzy and hit that like button Leigh
is very important and we're going to use
this to kind of basis for any kind of
code that we really write like in Hazel
like if you look at the building blocks
of kind of a game engine which I might
make a video soon about now that we're
kind of a little bit more clear on the
architecture of hazel we're kind of
going to review kind of how that works
but we basically plan aside you know we
create an application and we create a
layout and then that's kind of it the
applications kind of a core runtime and
the game loop and all that stuff of our
thing and then Leia is actually the
stuff that renders and receive events
and thus it's kind of a thing that we
both see the user kind of sees in the
form of rendering and also interacts
with in the form of that of events so
it's kind of a really
a building block of kind of the core
engine and something that obviously
we're going to use a lot in the future
if you want to spoil the serious
patriarchal 4/2 Turner huge thank you as
always I don't need to keep telling you
guys that this seriously wouldn't be
here without you guys I really am
thankful because it's amazing how like a
nice core section of the community can
be so generous as to help support this
series and then the rest of you guys
kind of get to see it for free so I
really am thankful to those guys and
that's why they receive rewards such as
all the code behind the scenes of hazel
and all the stuff that I've written in
my spare time as well as videos one week
earlier you play the next video in which
we probably will start implementing I'm
GUI is already up for patrons so yeah
hope you guys enjoy this video thank you
for watching and I'll see you next time
goodbye
[Music]